do you think being pragmatic hurts
acting in some sense because so many
people have said before they crossed
over and quote-unquote made it that they
were almost delusional in some sense
because they kept at it I mean yes the
odds are so stacked against someone and
I think that that does hurt a lot of
people sort of that analysis paralysis
where you overthink things and you
realize the odds are not in your favor
whereas it's helped you with medicine
but do you think in some sense someone
almost needs that that blind ambition
sort of those delusions yeah I I do
I think the delusional people are people
that I admire like all these delusional
types that are out there who are going
you know going to the right places
meeting the right people and in in
auditioning you know thousands auditions
a year those are the guys that
eventually make it I mean they do the
but the thing is you have to understand
who you are first so the key is really
understanding who you are and then and
then being true to yourself I'm not
delusional I'm a practical thinker I'm
very pragmatic and I'm a professional
above all else so I have to create a
different way to get there
I find that delusional the people with
that type of personality will some of
them definitely make it and they and
they try and keep going in that
direction but they have a high attrition
rate as well they tend to burn out with
I think pragmatic and practical thinkers
I feel that we tend to set a goal and
they stick to it so I think that is
where the advantage lies I think the
advantage for the practical thinker lies
in dedication perseverance and being
unwavering to a commitment so for when a
when a practical or pragmatic person is
a professional makes a commitment they
stick to it so my commitment is to make
films and to be recognized as an actor
at some point so until that occurs I
will continue to make films and figure
out a way to make it
so I suppose you may be thinking well
that is slightly delusional and in and
of itself so yeah I mean there I guess
there's different ways to be eccentric I
suppose so for me my centricity is in in
a belief that I can keep propelling
forward in filmmaking and doing it my
own way as opposed to the mainstream way
you